hi guys it's Greg here with Andrew here
Andrew here as a prepared statement he
had he's from the movie source channel a
lot of great movie reviews on there and
other topics here and there go check
them out Andrews you know reoccurring
guests on this channel anyway we're
gonna do an unboxing video today Andrew
I'm wearing a Deadpool shirt what am I
thinking
I don't what am I you're thinking I'm
thinking that there might be a t-shirt
and what might be unveiled today we're
gonna do an unboxing video for the Lego
Batman I just stopped in here there's
all kinds of stuff that's gonna be in
here before we do that I must give a
disclaimer please include a disclaimer
stating I Gregory Alba have received the
products from Warner Brothers consumer
products and the Lego Batman movie for
content creation purposes I will use the
hashtags hashtag sponsored and hashtag
Lego Batman movie alright let's open
this [ __ ] Andrew please unveil what's in
the box so down alright well look I
won't look now go from like least
interesting to most interesting right
the YouTube algorithm is more about the
retention and how long people are
staying so you gotta you know really
build this one up what we got there oh
we got a Batman watch a Batman wha
yeah you can't go wrong with Batman Lake
Oh - Lego format wash oh oh we're gonna
open this that's so sick think you can
put it together like Legos oh yeah it's
you know what you know what this watch
is so cute and so cool but I know Andrew
loves toys I do I really do and my
Jewish friend is getting a Christmas
present a little late here's one of your
few Christmas present I didn't put it in
the box correctly I thought if we got to
leave oh yeah here you go thank you
here you go it doesn't fit on my wrist
so I give it to you as a collectible
thanks buddy
yeah that's the kind of friend I am I
was so excited if it fit on my wrist you
wouldn't have got it
come on Andrew what we got next we've
got Lego minifigure oh okay you open
that one I'll open this one all right
you should have equipped us with
scissors I would have been throwing some
Lego scissors in the box that would have
been logical we don't do logic here oh
oh I think I know who I got Andrew I'm
sorry but I'm definitely keeping this
one why did Andrew you man oh my gosh
you and your problems okay okay you
finished putting this one together
because I don't have you they go some
more complicated than people made about
them get the g-man
you got mr. J this is Commissioner
Gordon oh good last name I like you
Commissioner Gordon is everyone's
favorite Batman character little bit a
little cool that Batman in there but
whatever that was you still got the best
villain of all time Joker
and I don't know how little kids do this
this is amazing and it happily goes
growing up money so we got Commissioner
Gordon here and the Joker you would
think it's Batman who's taking in the
Joker right but either way now after
Gordon still say it's awesome it's
awesome
everything is awesome right everything
is all guys like my little lego joke
there next one
Oh what's this Batman Batman what looks
like another Lego Batman figure oh but
he Jay
yeah that's that's a good keychain one
how do you feel about it I feel like if
you want you can have it do you want it
I'm a good friend - good yeah the will
are now I might want it no it's you this
might sharp a conversation oh it's the
Will Arnett Batman if a babe everyone's
favorite yeah Will Arnett will direct
the new Batman but it's time to voice
and direct them yeah I got a lot of
Legos in here
lots of them looks pretty cool we got
motorcycles set of Batgirl Robin and
Catwoman oh hell yeah oh yeah sick dude
let's just spend the next 45 minutes
putting together now yeah and you got
lay it looks like the old-school Robin
like the girl version from the Dark
Knight Returns yeah Carrie Kelly right I
know you're thinking of Dick Grayson
that's the original female sorry
Victory's Yeah right and she had all
this trauma because she was named after
a boy that's what she became yeah but
it's the correct accurate version from
comic story all right thanks to the guy
wearing Deadpool shirt but anyways I do
like that the old-school versions they
have them in here of Robin Catwoman and
Batgirl it's the old style version so
it's pretty sick wait
like don't wear I'll give you one of
these Legos Clayface Clayface and Batman
else we got on here you got a random
woman just looks like a random
bystandard okay so that one has Batman
it and Clayface anybody played Arkham
City Yeah right by the way I love the
design of Clayface with the Legos it's
pretty actually freaking it yeah it
looks I like it fits for him after they
got the Batarang coming into there it's
pretty cool you like the road the
battering at him pretty cool looks like
we can make a lego movie ourselves guys
alright figure we change up the pace for
one of these alright we have a t-shirt
that's a shirt it is what what what Oh
some pants or boxers these are for kids
oh nice you can always give them to your
neighbor kids see these are boxers I
thought these are shorts boxers
yeah if they're boxers I'm your gift oh
these are boxers yeah those are sick
those are giant boxers I love those
those are really giant boxers no this is
these are for kids this is a kid shorts
and this is a kid shirt it's gonna say
you could have obviously you know it
sure you could always give me your kids
neighbors that is the neighbors that you
love hear so much I mean would you want
this shirt maybe for my kids one day I
mean I promise you some gifts yeah I'll
take that
that sure just actually really obviously
even fit me I mean it's still really
cool shirt this is an amazing shirt look
print on that is amazing
that is look this is more likely to fit
into your body than mine
hey as I guess it's a two-piece I don't
want to give these other cool but these
are just way too small right
that is cool though you can have the
ears in your boxers more look is that
the Batmobile oh no bill well you can
have the admiration you have for
Clayface thanks man and I'll keep this
off but this one is pretty sick too but
the Batmobile you can't go wrong with
the Bell such as man and you got also
you got the man bat on here and then who
else we got on there you got the kabuki
twins kabuki twins and man bad dr. Kirk
Langstrom so that's really cool oh it's
Batman and Robin both in the battle oh
yeah there that's so cool how they put
both seats in there I love that that's
great you know it's not keeping the
giant one you want this one - that was
hesitant to give this one up this one
looks really old
I like the motorcycle with Catwoman in
there right there you can have those two
and all the giant one yeah thank you
these are really cool thank you still
think we have oh we got more before we
do we do way to save the best for last
Andrew no we got a couple more still
don't what's this I didn't even see this
one in there it's a Lego comic story
activities book oh cool so some reading
bathroom material
oh sweet I like to use the bathroom
that's like a full-blown comic book oh
oh pretty cool that's a great Aquash
less cool photos in here that's actually
pretty cool I like that actually
scarecrow that was like a whole story
there's some neat imagery in there that
reflects the Legos that were given
that's actually really cool like oh
that's so cool
all right sure reading material thanks
buddy
Oh posters you know I like my pose I'm
keeping that I'm keeping that I figured
I'm Keith oh wow you can't even fit this
into them totally oh yeah and I like the
spotlight coming down shiny like and how
they're imposing that's a cool picture
that is pretty sick I do like it
question is where is it going in your
place oh it's gonna go right above my
bed nice that way the ladies know I like
to play with Legos smart yeah one more a
shirt another one let's help this one
fits me I don't know I don't think
you're will that's true it isn't a
really cool shirt though that's amazing
that shirt
it is that's a pretty cool straight is
really cool that is a really a bunch of
haha' with a joker at the bottom that's
pretty cool it's about as on the nose as
Jared Leto's Joker going for it he's
going for it I'd be rocking a shirt in
today's video of Batman go for it oh boy
this is going to be interesting if I can
just get my head through here uh-uh
this is where the shirt rips apart oh
boy
not gonna lie that look pretty tough I'm
gonna need your okay this often all
right guys so you can go watch the Lego
Batman movie which is being released
item Chokey right now 2017 the Lego
Batman movie guys and Warner Brothers
thank you so much for all your help
February 10th this is so sexy how are
you not wanting to do things to me right
now
February 10th Asia there's a bunch of
Lego Batman collectibles out that are on
the market I'm sure of it buy some stuff
subscribe to the rejects my arms like
this shirt they are popping out oh yeah
haha I never realized the tighter the
better it doesn't look kind of like the
stray remember those Stretch Armstrong
things when we were growing up as kids
the stretch that you remember those are
not we don't have time to talk about
this subscribe to the real rejects and
and we resource you get this off
[Music]